Hi! I'm Anna Bernstein, founder of the Brain-Voice Connection.
A question that people should be asking me...
...is, "How can I lead a teleconference with authority?"
You know, there's really just a few simple rules...
...for taking a teleconference and making it a fabulous experience.
First of all, you have to be willing to take charge.
At the very outset, you run through the agenda.
You let people know that you will be watching the time.
You have to say you'll cut them off if they go over too much.
The next thing is always use their names when addressing them.
Some people are in the room, but the ones on the phone don't know who you're referring to.
A little tip that I like...
...is try to have pictures of the people who aren't there in the room with you.
That way, people have something to look at while that person is speaking.
Finally, consider the teleconference an incredible opportunity to sound like a leader.
If this is a presentation you're making to a prospect,...
...the fact that you have taken charge during this teleconference...
...demonstrates your leadership abilities for the project ahead.
Don't be afraid to step in and show them that you're the one that can run things.